[Music]
how did George and Tammy fall into your
lap I know there's gonna be a story of
like it took years because God forbid it
happens quickly in this industry can you
tell us about how you ended up here yeah
it was my the first time at the Golden
Globes 2011. I think and Josh Brolin
approached me and by the way I was like
I'd never been anything like the Golden
Gloves before so even a movie star
coming up to me I was like what is
happening and then he said have you ever
thought about playing Tammy Wynette I
think you should I was like all right
yes and uh so it had many iterations the
script hadn't even been written yet by
Abe there were a lot of directors and
what you know but it definitely happened
it was more than a decade uh it
definitely happened the way it was
supposed to be because that was during
that time I got to read all of her books
and the books about her and you know
listen to all the music and talk to the
family and and really immerse myself
into who she was and also you know we
got to work on all the music when it's
when it's a six hour mini series as
opposed to our film and then I got to
work with this guy right here too so it
definitely happened the way it should
have been
uh Michael
uh you two work together on take shelter
and then you got the band back together
uh for this
um what was your greatest challenge in
accepting this role and jumping into
uh such difficult people to portray I
don't know how much of the series that
you guys want has anyone watched the
entire run okay good all right all right
all right all right I'm trying not to do
spoilers so yes uh can you talk about uh
getting into George
well yeah I mean I didn't really know
anything about George uh
[Music]
at all and
um Jessica had been with it a lot longer
than I mean you'd been like a 10 years
and uh
yeah so I kind of came in at the last
minute and um
yeah I remember George when I was a kid
I used to see him on that show Hee Haw
on TV
and he looked familiar but I didn't
really know his his music all that much
but one of my best friends uh Paul
Sparks when he because I was kind of
waffling about it because I I just was
intimidated by it and then
my friend Paul he said they want you to
play George oh you got to play George
Jones and he started playing me all
these George Jones songs on the radio
um and um and I realized one by one so
many of my friends uh were massive
George Jones fans and I had no idea
um
it was like a secret or something so
yeah everybody said oh you should do it
and then
um
yeah yeah I just started by you know
reading all the books I get my hands on
and and watching uh performances and
interviews and
you know kind of The Logical things you
do when you're trying to find out about
somebody uh and then um and I had the
great pleasure of being able to meet uh
his daughter Georgette and his good
friend uh peanut and Peanut's wife
Charlene who had spent so much time with
them and uh
just listen to all the stories they had
to tell yeah
thank you uh Rachel so
obviously
these two are singing live on set it is
a challenge to even just imagine like
lip syncing but then also to sing live
on setting get it and that music
producing I feels like one of the
undervalued jobs of uh on on TV and in
film because they think you know you
just play a track and then that's it
there's obviously more to it than that
can you talk about uh
watching Michael and Jessica get into
get into the roles and then
get them ready to vocally rise to the
challenge
yeah
um one thing about producing that people
don't really talk about is there's a lot
of psychology in it there's a lot of
learning people and and they're two very
different people you know there was
Community communication Style with her
and a communication Style with him
um Michael has an avid music background
Jessica not as much and so it was
approaching them differently and
figuring out kind of what made them tick
and that kind of thing and
we had the chance to do that in
Nashville they came before we started
filming
and we they sang two three rounds of all
the songs in a span of about 10 days
and uh we did that as kind of a safety
for on set you know in case something
happened and we were able to put their
vocals in their ear so that they could
kind of match that as they were singing
on set so we had a little bit of
continuity but um yeah it was it was we
didn't know initially uh how much on set
we would be able to use in the final
thing and we were very pleased that we
were able to use about 95 of what they
sang on set and it's because they did
the work and and they were willing to do
20 takes and and you know we were able
to use it so we were really happy with
that yeah
uh Michael Jessica can you talk about
the research that you did uh I know you
said you know you spoke to a lot of
um of their friends and and obviously
their daughter so you said
um what other
types of things that you plan or did you
look into to properly prepare
uh well I got her cookbook I started
making some things she because she loved
to cook
and um
I mean it was disgusting stuff
I can't even I mean I think I showed you
some of the recipes it was pretty like
wow I can't believe
she everyone didn't just die when they
were really young
um so that was fun to kind of just play
around with that and then uh of course
because I had so much time to listen to
her and how she sang and
um in her inflections but I really music
was so important to her I wanted to
listen to who her Inspirations were so
there was a lot of listening to like
Kitty Wells and Lefty and Hank Williams
and the loom brothers and kind of like
the music history of who she would have
grown grown up with listening to I found
that to be really
um exciting and kind of like immersive
uh yeah and then the books that she
wrote the books that other people wrote
I I and then YouTube my God she's all
over YouTube uh especially the two of
them performing together and we took a
lot directly from things that happened
to them on set on set on stage uh and so
it was just constantly you know Mike
would come into my trailer and I just
had YouTube on all the time with their
performances
well the studio where we did the
pre-records at
uh that Rachel was talking about uh
right behind the studio was a big
Cemetery
and uh it just so happens that it's the
cemetery where George is buried and
where Tammy's remains are in the
mausoleum so we would go over there
and yeah and visit with them and
meditate on that and
um
they're both very
overwhelming uh particularly Tammy's
spot in the mausoleum you want to talk
about that well the first time you went
there and it was all covered with all
these beautiful pictures family photos
but also things that people had drawn
and left and cards that people had
written to her you were quite uh
overwhelmed by that
um
and then going to if you've never seen
George's grave
I'm sure there's probably pictures of it
online it's it's also
pretty uh powerful but it's a little
disconcerting because it's um
seems to be very much
um about as much more about his wife
than than him unfortunately but uh
and but it's interesting because Billy
Cheryl is buried directly across from
him and it's a little enclosure it's
fenced off they have their own little
there's a few other uh folks in there
but uh yeah I don't know I found that
kind of helpful and um
yeah I'm just being in Nashville in
general and spending time at the Ryman
Auditorium we actually the last two days
of the shoot
were was it two or three two yeah yeah
we shot two days at the Ryman Auditorium
that's where Jessica is saying uh helped
me make it through the night
which she sang on the anniversary of
Tammy's death
on stage at the Ryman Auditorium so that
was pretty and I was watching that that
was
pretty uh spectacular and moving and um
yeah I sing a couple of songs here too
did you guys see episode one
so the whole beginning that's the Ryman
Auditorium him singing White Lightning
and all that that's and it's sacred
ground in Nashville
uh Rachel can you talk about what is
your what was your favorite scene to
watch them perform in in relation to
getting them prepared to sing or
act those parts out uh for Michael it
was definitely He Stopped Loving Her
Today which is episode six six
um
because he was adamant about Jess not
seeing him sing that in the rehearsals
which I loved and so that her reaction
was real and so when you see that scene
her reaction is real but he and I felt
like it made him go harder and it's just
it was moving and and that's actually
that's actually him singing in that
scene you know all the mics worked and
um and so that stands out for him for
sure
um for her uh
think it might have been helped me make
it through the night as well because uh
yeah just the Ryman
and I thought she did an amazing job on
that number as well
um and it was it was the last day of
shooting and it was the last number she
did it was on the day Timmy passed so
that was special so those those two
probably for sure if I may add because
one of the fascinating challenges of
doing that song I think is not only
because it's hard enough to just be
there and be singing but she has to be
in that state that Tammy's in of just
barely being able to function anymore
yeah and so it's hard enough just to
sing any of the numbers but to add on
top of it that
performance of the deteriorated State
she was in was it yeah yeah
or either you like inspired to like you
know drop an album at the end of the
shooting he's done it he's got an album
it's really good
and he's performing right now he's
already at his dropping Friday he's got
a band called Corporal and that's how I
knew you know when we were doing take
shelter he gave me a copy of a CD and I
put it in the Jukebox in Ohio Grafton
Ohio uh the bar that we used to hang out
at so maybe it's still there in that
jukebox if grafton's still there
um can you talk about the physical
Transformations that you two had to
undergo could I believe I want to make
sure I'm not misspeaking same eyes of
Tammy Faye makeup team yeah always
always so I've been working with these
ladies since 2011 I'm so lucky I love
them so much Molly's game every look
that I've done Miss slow every is so
vastly different and they're incredibly
it's Linda Dows and Stephanie Ingram
they are geniuses and beautiful people
so yes I worked with them on this as
well but it was different in that eyes
of Tammy Faye was a lot of Prosthetics
and this Linda painted my face so in
episode six there's a flashback where I
mean Tammy deteriorates quite a bit and
Barry she ages up a lot
um
I think you know she died when she was
55 and she looked much older than that
and uh so
Linda was able to paint in a way that
was just really kind of sad and
disturbing and then also we work
alongside each other because I lost a
ton of weight for that we shot in
chronological order is to kind of help
with the
um
what was happening to her
and then you lent them to Michael and
then well I didn't gain any weight I
just wore it up into the pad yeah I
didn't want to do that bacon
cheeseburger thing I don't know how the
guys do that and then they get rid of
the weight afterwards
I wouldn't it's hard enough to
to maintain my figure as it is so I
didn't do that I just took a pillow and
put it in there but there were lots of
uh wigs and sideburns and
um
yeah but I I had a pretty swell team
myself particularly uh
Ashley Chavez didn't my makeup and she
was
she was lovely and um
yeah you know uh we would we were
usually in the trailer for about an hour
every morning
no matter what the look was I had to
look kind of different than how I
normally look yeah
how long were you in uh makeup to
prepare for each day well for the older
stuff it was much longer
um for both of us though I mean there
were times I I remember because they put
up would put a bald cap on you before
they would put the hair right I got a
picture on my phone actually if anybody
wants to see it
um so it was it was quite a long time
and we would play soothing you know in
the beginning of the day we had all this
country music and at the end I just know
to like play very calm soothing music
because I just see Mike in the chair
like get it off and freaking out
uh my final question to you guys and I I
thoroughly feel that anytime an actor
whether it's a TV show or a film is a
piece of that character that remains
with you whether even not just an acting
but also as music producing or directing
or writing there's something of that
story that remains with you can you talk
about what is your fondest memory or
something that you always remember after
working on George and Tammy we'll start
with Rachel and work our way down
think
for me it I mean I certainly this
certainly caused me to dive into their
music you know a lot and I'd always kind
of you know in the country music scene
they're very well respected that they've
also been parodied and kind of
you know made fun of a little bit
they're kind of been seen it's like not
not taken seriously as people their
music is taken seriously but and and I
just loved that this whole story made
them human and made them real very you
know relatable people
um and so I came out of this project
really respecting them a lot more
um and uh what was it question was it
specific
just a specific scene I mean or just or
just anything that from the experience I
mean definitely all the people I met for
sure um the last scene of the show which
hopefully everyone's maybe seen it by
now but uh they're all on the bus
together and that was a really special
scene because uh their daughter
Georgette was in the scene it was close
to end of rapping me and the showrunner
were like crying outside the bus while
they're singing inside the bus because
we're like oh my gosh you know it was a
very sweet scene they all sing together
on this on the bus and um it's a really
good close to the show but it was a
special scene as they filmed it and
Georgette got emotional that day seeing
them dressed up as her parents she
actually cried and hugged him and said
you know you remind me of my dad so much
and that was sweet and so I remember
that day being a very warm day or that
that filming for
passing
no I I I you know it'd be really hard to
come up with the short answer to that
question really
um
I mean look at the end of the day it's
you know it's called George and Tammy so
the the main thing I take away from it
is
the the relationship
um
that we created and um
it's just really it's really deep
complicated relationship I mean it's
it's a tragic love story but it's also
filled with a lot of beauty and
um
I guess the thing I related to is
trying to balance
the way George was he kept trying to
figure out it was like he was at a fork
in the road all the time and he couldn't
figure out do I go this way or do I go
that way and and
he never entirely felt comfortable no
matter what decision he made and he
tried it seemed like he tried
he really wanted to be a good person
like he just really really wanted to be
a good person and he wanted to be a good
partner
for Tammy and he just couldn't
he couldn't figure it out but but he
remained steadfast
his whole life even after she passed
you know we were talking earlier today
he would write letters to radio DJs and
say someone should be looking into this
it's not right something something's
fishy here and
and I know he swore up and down a stack
of Bibles that Nancy was his true love
and saved his life and all the rest of
it but
I don't know it's just just one of the
most powerful connections I've ever seen
between two people
thank you
um for me it's I mean definitely that
Mike and I have been friends for so long
and and to even think about embarking on
anything like this I've never had as
Rachel said I don't have a music
background I mean I did some singing in
the eyes of Tammy Faye it was a very
different kind of thing
and you know when you're singing it on
set which honestly I didn't understand
that we were doing this and it wasn't
really until Mike got involved or you
know he's so much about authenticity and
it needs to like we don't want this to
be cheesy it needs to be real we need to
be like performing that I realize oh
we're doing this live on set and what
that means is you have we have earwigs
it's not like we're performing for you
guys at bands playing and then we get to
sing with the band
the first take you guys hear the music
and then after that we have these the
earwigs in our ear that plays the music
and we have a microphone and we just
sing along but you guys can't hear the
music and it's the way to get the vocal
clean
and that is scary when you're belting
Stand By Your Man in front of a bunch of
people and it's just a cold vocal with
no
sound with it it's terrifying I mean I
oh God
I don't know when I finished that scene
actually I said to Rachel I will never
sing that song again but then I was on
my way home and I was singing it in the
car
I want to add to that though that I feel
like you know the theme of this show
seemed to be for me for them to be
outside your comfort zone and I feel
like these two are where they're at
because they go towards the scary stuff
they go towards the uncomfortable stuff
um
uh and and yeah I just wanted to note
that because it was I mean I would I
hats off because I was like I don't know
how she's doing but I was trying to be
your cheerleader on the side but like
there was yeah
specialty is that what we call yeah
especially my medicinal tea medicinal
tea and it was a hot toddy yeah with
with burb in it but uh but yeah I mean
200 people in the audience and and she's
just doing an acapella so I think yeah
hats off to both of these guys
empty
I did like your approach as I get her to
sing I appreciate that a lot I know we
all it's not real unless we hear it
right now
um so I'm gonna end with this I would uh
like to kindly ask Michael Shannon and
Jessica Justine to not make us wait 11
more years before you work together
again please hey we might do a play next
actually because we did a film we did
television and now we're like hey maybe
we'll do a play
[Music]